find the area of the semicircle so pause
this video and see if you can figure it
out
so let's see we know that the area of a
circle is equal to
pi
times our radius squared
so if we think about the entire circle
what is the area going to be
well they tell us what our radius is our
radius is equal to 2.
so the area if we're talking about the
whole circle it would be equal to pi
times 2 squared
pi times 2 squared 2 squared is of
course 2 times 2 which is equal to 4. so
our area is going to be equal to 4
times pi
now i wouldn't put 4 pi here because
that would be the entire
circle they want the area of just the
semicircle of just this region right
over here well the semicircle is half of
the circle so if i want the area of the
semicircle it's just going to be half
this so instead of 4 pi it is going to
be 2 pi
square units that's the area of the
semicircle let's do another example
so here instead of area we're asked to
find the arc length of the partial
circle and that's what we have here in
this bluish color right over here find
this arc length and you can see this is
going three-fourths of the way around
the circle so this arc length is going
to be 3 4 of the circumference
so what is the circumference well we
know the circumference is equal to 2
pi
times the radius
they tell us what the radius is it's
equal to 4. so our circumference
is equal to 2 pi
times
4.
let's see we can just change the order
in which we multiply so it's 2 times 4
times pi this is going to be equal to
8 pi
this is going to be equal to 8 pi now
that is the circumference of the entire
circle
if we care about this arc length it's
going to be 3 4 times the circumference
of the entire circle
so 3 over 4
times
8 pi
what is that going to be
well what's 3 4 times 8
well 3 times 8 is 24 divided by 4 is 6.
so this is going to be equal to
6 pi
another way to think about it 1 4 of 8
is 2 so 3 4 is going to be 6. or another
way to think about it is 1 4 of 8 pi is
2 pi and so 3 of those is going to be
equal to 6 pi
so the arc length of the partial circle
is
6 pi and once again we knew that because
it was 3 4 of the way around the way
that i knew it was 3 4 is that this is a
90 degree angle this is 90 degrees which
is one-fourth of the way around a circle
so the arc length that we care about is
the three-fourths
of our circumference